PAIGE BAILEY: Hi,
I'm Paige Bailey,
and I'm a TensorFlow
developer advocate at Google,
here for TensorFlow Meets
with Sebastian Thrun,
founder of Udacity,
founder of Google X,
renowned deep learning
researcher, and--
did I miss anything?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: [LAUGHS]
That's good enough.
PAIGE BAILEY:
[LAUGHS] Excellent.
So we're really
excited to have you
here today to talk
about the new Udacity
course for TensorFlow 2.0.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about it?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Well,
it's our second course
between my company,
Udacity, and Google.
We launched the original
TensorFlow course a while back.
And over 40,000 students
took this free course
and became TensorFlow
developers,
which is really amazing.
I think it's the most
successful platform ever.
Now, with the launch of
TensorFlow 2.0 Alpha,
we have a new course,
right on time,
called Introduction to
TensorFlow, Induction
to Deep Learning.
And you can find it on the
web at Udacity.com/TensorFlow.
PAIGE BAILEY: Perfect.
And for the students who
are taking the course,
I know that sometimes they might
feel a little bit apprehensive,
that maybe they
don't necessarily
have the mathematical background
they need in order to be
successful at deep learning.
Is that really the case,
or does this course kind
of take them from
zero to deep learning
engineer just within the
space of a few lessons?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: So we
are really changing this.
I agree, many courses
require a lot of math.
We don't.
Students can sign up without
any PhD or any extensive math
experience.
And here's the cool
thing about TensorFlow,
it actually makes computer
program easier, not harder.
And the reason is, in the past,
to be a software engineer,
you had to give
these dumb computers
a step by step recipe
called software what to do.
And these dumb
computers would have
to follow every single step,
and that is actually pretty hard
to do.
Now, with TensorFlow
2.0, all you do is you
train based on examples, right.
You give examples
to the computer,
and the computer find its
own rules that actually makes
programming easier, not harder.
So I encourage
anybody in the world,
no matter what your
background is, to try it out.
And you can become
a TensorFlow expert.
PAIGE BAILEY: It feels
pretty magic, right,
to be able to take data and then
whatever your expected output
should be, and to be able to
generate the rules that you
would otherwise have to
painstakingly turn into FL
statements or something.
SEBASTIAN THRUN:
Yeah, and it's amazing
what happens right now in
society thanks to TensorFlow
and deep learning.
We now in medicine
have examples where
TensorFlow gets better results
than the best human physicians.
In law, we have
areas like, whatever,
legal document
discovery and contract
drafting, where the TensorFlow
outperforms the best
human experts.
Self-driving cars now massively
use TensorFlow these days.
So there are so many areas
where you can take your skills
and bring them to the
betterment of rules
if you just take
this one free course.
PAIGE BAILEY: Yes.
And I heard also, I believe,
that you guys are using machine
learning for Udacity to optimize
your curriculum for students as
well, right?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yes, so
we've massively used machine
learning to help sort students
into the right curriculum
and then helping them
making through it,
because our goal at Udacity
is to close the talent
gap and the skills
gap and really empower
everybody to have a job
in the modern world.
So that's part of our strategy.
PAIGE BAILEY: Excellent.
So it sounds like students,
all they would have to do is go
to Udacity.com/TensorFlow,
sign up for the free course,
and begin the learning
experience to find out all
about TensorFlow 2.0.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah,
and in this free course,
we have a guarantee.
If you don't like it,
you get your money back.
PAIGE BAILEY: [LAUGHS] Awesome.
So remember to try out
our TensorFlow 2.0 course
on Udacity at
Udacity.com/TensorFlow.
And if you have any comments
for me or for Sebastian,
make sure to leave them
in the field below.